[Musique]
dans ce village au nord d'abidjan
c'est un griot un conteur musicien qui
met la population en garde contre le coc
vite 19 le but éviter tout contact entre
les 10000 habitants que compte
l'agglomération
bonjour ce message concerne le
coronavirus c'est une maladie très
dangereuse
respectons les distances 1 mètre entre
les gens
arrêtons de manger de la viande de
brousse ici aux aguets nous avons un
moyen encore plus pratique de fait
passer le message surtout avec le haut
parleur
voilà ça nous permet d'éviter le contact
voilà la somme permet d'éviter le
contact et le message est véhiculé tout
le monde comprend l'enjeu local en
langue locale et surtout en français une
quinzaine de hauts parleurs pour
remplacer les crieurs de rue un procédé
mis en place dans de nombreuses autres
localités ivoiriennes à l'initiative des
nombreux rois que compte le pays et les
chefs de village pour tenter de rassurer
les populations
voir je suis passé des réelles c'est
quoi la maison rien monsieur qui avait
nommé s'agit pas là mais
elle opine ici comme dans de nombreuses
régions du globe
pas d'eau courante pas de gel
hydroalcoolique non plus quant aux
masques
le sujet n'est même pas évoquée nous
n'avons pas beau mais il faut se laver
les mains
ici quand heures vous êtes arrivé vous
n'avez pas constaté est ce petit robinet
qui devait vous permettre de vous laver
les mains ça veut dire que nous n'avons
pas d'eau et sain où le clion vraiment
la côte d'ivoire contre des centaines de
rois et de chef depuis 2016
la chambre nationale des rois et chefs
traditionnels leur donne une
reconnaissance officielle et un rôle
consultatif
en parallèle à l'organisation politique
du pays
ce dimanche un premier mort dû aux
coronavirus a été recensés en côte
d'ivoire qui compte une centaine de cas
l'état d'urgence a été déclaré un
couvre-feu est entrée en vigueur sur
tout le territoire